at a late night crime scene in
tegucigalpa a shootout raged between
gang members and police in the
villanueva neighborhood leaving at least
seven dead
there is insecurity for everyone we
can't live here any longer but we've no
place else to go because other places
are dangerous too we're in dire need and
i don't know what to do stay here or
leave the country
many here say blood-soaked streets
littered with bullet casings have become
an all too common sight
authorities tell us that scenes of
brutal violence like this one in the
honduran capital are just the tip of the
iceberg in a far more complex security
situation that affects nearly every
corner of the country
in honduras poorest neighborhoods gangs
particularly ms-13 and the 18th street
gang are notorious for crimes like
extortion and for the recruitment of
young children those who resist often
pay with their lives
this young mother who has asked us to
hide her identity says she was tortured
by gang members and forced to flee her
home after refusing to pay extortion
money
we've faced humiliation we've lost our
house because of the gangs my children
cry and say to me mom it would be good
for us to go someplace else where they
won't want to kill us imagine a
seven-year-old boy saying that to you
a lack of confidence in honduran
authorities means victims of violence
seldom report crimes to police and
security experts say collusion between
criminal groups and government officials
permeates across all levels of society
unfortunately we see that different
politicians and government leaders have
been linked to drug trafficking we see
that there are high rates of impunity
corruption and weakness in the rule of
law
a deputy police commissioner tells al
jazeera that despite modest advances in
reducing the national homicide rate
reigning in the violence often feels
like a losing battle
in
comparison in comparison to previous
years the incidence of crime has
actually decreased but perhaps in some
communities it's risen due to factors
like local culture or in communities
where gangs exist in great numbers
has a rate of 38 homicides per 100 000
residents making it one of the most
dangerous countries in latin america
international observers predict that
thousands of hondurans will be displaced
from their homes in 2022 a challenge
that cannot be addressed without a
drastic reduction in the violence
plaguing the country
manuel rapalo al jazeera tegucigalpa